charlie munger had some absolutely wild
things to say yesterday about inflation
bitcoin and fiat currencies as we know
charlie munger has not been a fan of
bitcoin for a long time but he
specifically said yesterday that he
believes high inflation should be taken
very very seriously he said that's how
societies and democracies fall so
ultimately you'd believe somebody who
thinks high inflation is a massive
problem would be into bitcoin right no
but before we get to the bitcoin
conversation here's charlie on fiat
currencies he actually believes it's all
going to zero don't believe me here's
exactly what he said a safe assumption
for an investor is that over the next
100 years the
currency is going to zero
that's my working hypothesis
wow well that'll be a different type of
environment won't it now of course
absolutely hilarious yes that'll be a
very different type of environment to
recap exactly what some of munger's
thoughts are first he believes fiat
currencies are all going to zero they'll
all be worthless over the next 100 years
he then went on to say that bitcoin he's
not a fan it's a venereal disease
reminds me of the old lil wayne song now
of course he isn't a fan of bitcoin so
would he be a fan of gold no civilized
people don't buy gold according to him
so if fiat currencies are worthless
bitcoin is worthless and gold is
worthless what the hell has any value
anymore now ultimately he's previously
said bitcoin's rat poison and a whole
bunch of other crazy stuff but now he's
saying fiat currencies are going to zero
my favorite part of the interview was
when he said that he's actually proud to
not have invested in bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies over the last few years
but if we go ahead and we check the
scoreboard if we take a look berkshire
hathaway is up 87 over the last five
years ethereum of 23 000
and bitcoin up 4 000
maybe charlie munger should actually
lose some of that pride maybe he should
be a little bit more intellectually
humble i think he's going down the right
path when he's talking about fiat
currencies ultimately being worthless
because governments and central banks
can't stop printing more they can't stop
debasing them but maybe he should
actually start looking for what the
solution is i think that if he does a
little bit more work if he stops being
intellectually lazy he'd actually find
that bitcoin is inevitable